you go from the nickel fellowship to
then writing some very fascinating
scenes so you had some activity in the
film so what would you give what advice
would you tell a first or second time
director about orchestrating a sex scene
and you're not in the valley you're
you're doing rehearsals or maybe you're
not privacy is everything you have to
look out for your actors first and
foremost and make sure that the
situation is comfortable and there's
already you know people leering you know
from behind camera or whatnot you have
to really really just be very it's all
about the actors and you know and also
there's nothing I don't think there
could be anything less sexy than
shooting a sex scene so mechanical and
you know so it's there's there's no
glory in making and shooting one of
those things I don't think really but
that for this movie it was very
important to get that on on film